it's a bullying Capcom exclusive how
98.3 men who like Cabell video got my
dude burner papi
burner burner burner man hey look first
things first everybody knows you reppin
that Taylor Gang but let's talk about
Arizona you have some roots here at AZ
talk about them I got strong roots and
AZ just like my second home I was out
here uh two six seven eight a little bit
of high school every time I get in
trouble stance just come out here when I
get in trouble here I go back to San
Francisco so yeah I got some of my best
client partners school out here oh where
do we go to school at what the Pueblo I
went down with the Pueblo Corona what
was a continuation school compadre
compadre I went to a bunch of places got
kicked out of there I think or dropped
out or one another but yeah man you know
Arizona is my second home that's what's
up man so uh you are from the Bay Area
you from San Francisco a lot of people
know you as like the weed guy I am
you are the weed guy begod can you
elaborate on on all that a little bit
for us
look I just always say like this you
know everyone always says who could
smoke the most that's just not possible
to decide that because you know someone
could be having something else going on
but at the end of the day we're always
gonna bring the best and that's just how
we always leave it so when it comes to
the trees no one's saying they can smoke
more anyone cuz how could you decide I'm
just gonna say we bring the best every
time no matter what no matter where we
are
if you smoked on the cookies that's
that's your you are uh yeah we've got a
circle of people in the beta just you
know kind of just scientists or the
cookies the wiser server the snowman or
all the good flavorful exotic things
that you don't have is probably coming
from a low camp that's what's up and
then it's cookies we got two closing
lines we got a we got cookies and then
me and Wiz got fresh go we're about to
drop on May first I want to talk to you
about this WorldStarHipHop video that
I'm a big fan yes yes yes you know you
you you had the trippy stick pop and
this was like before the Jeep nz6 or
even popular really yeah I'm a
trendsetter we did it first
yes and this chick was hidden hitting
the trippy state with her
[__] yeah who is this girl and where
is she now let's see I'd like to hang
out with is a thing about me a lot of
people know any city I go to the first
thing I do is hit a strip club you can
get a conversation pop in a strip club
faster than a regular Club true so I've
seen her I've seen that and I was like
god damn and she was Asian and it was
just amazing and I just walked out torn
hear what they you want to get a million
views on worldstar and what's girl
ratchet girl doesn't want to get a
million views on all right yeah yeah
yeah I told you guys smoke that's your
ass so I flew out to the bay and we
tried for about how or didn't happen
right away but she got it and she did it
and I should got her popular that's so
crazy that all it takes yeah you just
gotta you just gotta ask a girl do you
want to get a million views in the world
do anything
hey I mean a lot of you see that's
what's up man that's what's up um you of
course had a joint with where's that was
real big yourself Chris Brown whiz Big
KRIT the Yoko joint before you
officially Taylor game you've got the
joint that kind of like lets you get in
a deal with Wiz or you know was it just
because you guys were homies how did the
deal come to be with that I think you
know that was just like that was just
kind of the beginning of like just I was
doing music together I think what led to
us getting a deal is he just seemed my
grind he's seeing that you know I'm just
gonna keep working and I have a good
work ethic and I'm just about that every
kind of business possible I got several
businesses going on so one day when we
were I stopped by Southwest he just
couldn't ask me yo when we about to sign
and make it official and so we just did
it and it was probably the best decision
I could have made cuz you get to keep
all your creative control like he's not
making me trying to do different kind of
smiles and I like that he respects my
market and the fan base I've acquired
and built by myself and we're just gonna
just make it bigger
um will was telling me that you guys are
lying around Texas and you were like all
the essays were like like super stoked
is to see you out walking around yeah
man you know Mexicans rule the world
down there we're everywhere so that's
real yeah when they see me yeah that's
why you man I'm telling you right now
we're going to come back to Arizona
we're gonna turn it all the way you know
I got noble of all the Mexicans out
there but they're just choose to see a
artist in there that's not being
stereotyped like you see like you're not
like it Chicano rap yeah it's just I
just do me and it's just and they like
it and I don't need to brag on the fact
or nationality a more
yeah you know I'm not like being
profiled with like pull up stocks and
the big to my head and like a lowrider
I'm just just doing my music yeah
so I working out perfect oh you think
you got the fresh go clothing that's the
line what you will whiz right yeah we're
gonna drop it on the first we got 150
pieces of each design available for p.m.
fresco live common first the site's
probably crashed in the first minute but
some I'm gonna tell you that nobody
really knows yet some people may know on
the first we're gonna do a pop-up shop
in LA at the Beverly Center me was now
gonna be there just playing the new
clothing line of selling so no slide out
and see something big what were you
doing on 4/20 man we had the best meat
party in the world we were impose Oh a
bunch of drunk white girls Mexican girls
smoking enjoying life was huge see
you're probably I mean I mean how much
can you can you tell us the amount of
marijuana consumed that you you know he
might have gone through I mean you know
being on a roller game that's kind of
like it's the good stock Tori yeah yeah
you know I mean [__] I think we had what
when you walked into the building they
had like a little jar that said don't be
greedy in his full weed we didn't even
want that we had our own month I was
probably smoked about a half P that day
just between anyone like literally
that's what I brought in I left I got
had little nubs in my bag and we left so
you know the band the light guard the
sound guy the whole crew was all smoking
together now the mixtape urban farmer
did real well man I feel like that's
kind of like that kind of elevated your
popularity because of course once you
are associated with the tailgating brand
people are just more keen to check you
out if they hadn't heard of you before
what's next you got a album coming out I
mean is there another tape coming out
right now if you if you keep that on
just sort of you people are farmers a
producer Cosmo me did a lot of the best
production on there a lot of production
we're doing a tape that he's producing
completely called toast or cowboy that's
the next move Drugstore Cowboy
yeah that's the dope that's the dope
hasn't it yeah cuz you know everyone's
on lean right now there's big money and
everything so it's just had kind of
looked at like you know what I've
watched the movie back in the days there
was knocking off drugstores and selling
pills and kind of Wilin out so he just
kind of fits like what's going on now
but that that product or that project
about to drop I think June 11th and
gonna be crazy I'm turning all the way
up not seeing what urban farmer did and
I seen the potential right I didn't
farmer in a week that's great under
pressure because I remember I had to
knock it out so I'm really gonna just
take more time with this and just make
it was supposed to be do you mess with
the lien at all nah man was an ego man
okay
yeah Alexander's okay yeah I always feel
like the lien thing is like is it's
getting like that and Molly man it's
like almost like getting played out
people really if you out there sipping
lean there step your [__] life
it's like the new hair on right now
people don't even know yeah you know I
mean I've got love got a lot of lean
sippers man a lot of my friends to clean
I can't talk down on Rajas auntie's but
at that day don't drink a disgusting
amount just be normal don't you roll in
front of people don't fall out not it
out like you know don't back up you know
don't don't be able to not go to the
bathroom from it you know just Jesus
that's crazy
anyway hey yo so up tonight you do
anything Scottsdale what's going down
it's gonna be I'm sure a lot of snow
bunnies in the building yeah yeah all
the beautiful ladies all the Mexican
ladies are the way ladies every lady
just come out we're gonna be at the
martini ranch in Scottsdale my first
time being out here in a while
shout out to all the people at raw
papers to with us upon tomorrow yeah raw
papers they're they're based out of town
yeah they're here yeah I'm about to go
meet over my boys from raw right now you
know they they held us down for the tour
they're gonna be in a building to have a
free product for people it's gonna be a
great show that's what's up um hey for
everybody don't know man what can they
catch up on your older stuff cuz you've
been doing the indie thing for a long
yeah go to iTunes
um and even if you don't want to buy it
on iTunes you can just go to youtube and
type in burner really but iTunes I got
about 10 albums up on there and now I'll
slap from beginning to end so if you
like what you heard on heard of a farmer
you gonna love everything else there it
is burner hit him up on our Twitter
burner four one five right yep burner
four five Instagram burner four five
Facebook burner cell there it is power
98.3 shots a burner tonight the good
stock tour is in AZ go check them out
Chevy Woods tubes power 98.3